if you are living your life based on
your family's opinions you will always
end up in a not as happy place as you
can here's the key the thing that people
don't realize that happens is you start
getting resentment towards your family
so you're trying to make your mom and
dad sister brother happy what you're
actually doing is you're making yourself
angry at them and creating resentment
and you're actually hurting your
relationship more and it sometimes
manifests in blowing up and having a
fight and never talking or it's
subconscious staying away from as you
get older you spend less and less time
because you have resentment that you
listen to them and you don't have the
accountability that you could have not
listened to them you can respect your
family while living on your own terms
the number one thing people are dealing
with is being able to be happy with
themselves and so much of it has to do
with other people's opinions too many
people were brought up in households
that value to other people's opinions
the neighbors the elderly in the family
which some of it's beautiful respecting
your elders is a beautiful thing but not
living your truth is the beginning of
having internal emotional cancer